[Applaus]
[Musik]
heute liebe freunde sprechen darüber
südkorea oder die kommunen sagen würde
das böse korea
ihr habt vielleicht schon mal was man
dieses land gehört weil der eure handys
fernseher oder sogar autos hergestellt
wurden oder vielleicht weil es jedes
land ist aus dem dieses höchst
umstrittene lied kommt propaganda amstar
südkorea ist eine großmacht nicht nur
auf kultureller sondern auch auf
wirtschaftliche ich bin mir ziemlich
sicher dass ihr von euch mindestens ein
produkt von samsung oder lg sein eigenes
südkoreanische unternehmen haben die
weltwirtschaft im sturm erobert und das
überrascht wenn man bedenkt dass
südkorea noch in den 1960 er jahren ein
extrem armes land war
und nein wir sprechen hier nicht von
relativer armut anderer länder wie japan
oder simbabwe waren damals wesentlich
weiter entwickelt
[Musik]
außerdem legten die südkoreaner in nur
einer generation eine sagenhafte
karriere vom rande des forums zu einer
der wohlhabendsten gesellschaften dieses
planeten überhaupt und jetzt fragst du
dich ganz sicher wie die dessen bekommen
haben so reich zu werden
aber was einen moment meine lieben
freunde von visual politik ich weiß was
ihr denkt noch so ein video in dem wir
euch erklären wie ein land dann der
freien marktwirtschaft auf wundersame
weise reich werden konnte nicht wahr
nun da muss ich enttäuschen denn
institute ja nicht was ganz anders
[Musik]
natürlich ist südkorea im vergleich zu
seinem nördlichen nachbar ein paradies
der freiheit aber das südkoreanische
wird das modell hat eine ganz bestimmte
besonderheit die es ganz stark von
anderen kapitalistischen ländern
unterscheidet okay was also sind die
gründe die diesen unvergleichlichen
aufstieg koreas erklären und welche
frage noch wichtiger ist warum war games
teil im eigenen land ein derart
umstrittenes lied beide fragen sind eng
miteinander verwoben und wir werden euch
in diesem video auf beide fragen
antworten liefern
top down von oben nach unten wie ihr
wisst wurden die koreanische halbinsel
ein mit krieg in zwei hälften geteilt
in diesen krieg wurden mehr als zehn
prozent der bevölkerung koreas etwa drei
millionen menschen getötet das waren
mehr als immer viel bekannteren
vietnamkrieg zum zeitpunkt der teilung
war der süden der viel ärmere teil
koreas im norden konzentrierten sich so
gut wie alle bedeutenden industrie und
wirtschaftsunternehmen
[Musik]
der süden war landwirtschaftlich geprägt
ökonomisch unterentwickelt und sozial
arg zurück geblieben um sich das bild zu
verdeutlichen die schulen im süden
verfügten noch nicht mal über
schreibtische und die einzige mahlzeit
für die meisten kinder stellte das aus
den usa und europa gespendete
milchpulver da die menschen im süden
protestierten gegen diese greifende
armut und diese missstände
deshalb entschloss sich general park
chung hee im jahr 1960 gegen die
regierung zu pushen und übernahm die
macht
so begann die erste südkoreanische
diktatur
[Musik]
in den folgenden 27 jahren hatte dieses
land drei verschiedene diktatoren und
alle von ihnen kamen auf gewaltsame
weise an die macht in dem sie den
vorigen machthaber einfach stürzte und
dennoch wurde trotz dieser politischen
instabilität in jener zeit das
südkoreanische erfolgsmodell erschaffen
jetzt haltet aber mal einen mit ihnen
denn die wirtschaft war gar nicht zu
frei und marktwirtschaftliche jetzt
vielleicht denkt denn eine feier markt
zeichnet sich eigentlich durch seine
organisation von unten nach oben bottom
up aus die privatwirtschaft und die
verbraucher entscheiden wie wann und was
sie verkaufen bzw kaufen wollen dann
erst kommt der staat und die reihe und
reguliert all diese aktivitäten mithilfe
von gesetzen
nun gut einparken fußball galt das
genaue gegenteil
er etablierte ein top das system von
oben nach unten
seine politik bestand darin die
wichtigsten industriellen familien des
landes einen raum zu versammeln
darunter befanden sich auch die gründe
der firmen samsung und lg
[Musik]
er stellte sich vor sie und verkündete
von heute an werde ich euch alles zur
verfügung stellen damit er wachsen könnt
falls ja ein jahr lang keine steuern
zahlen könnt das ist okay ich werde sich
erlassen benötigt er subventionen
erteilt braucht ihr einen kredit aus dem
ausland die regierung wird dafür
geradestehen und burgen und selbst wenn
ihr eure schulden nicht begleichen könnt
wird euch der staat unter die arme
greifen
wenn mir schwachsinn ist unser land in
gefahr
damit ein land nicht scheitert muss es
seine eigene kraft heranzüchten dennoch
im gegensatz zu anderen ländern wie
frankreich legte südkorea dem
internationalen handel keine hindernisse
in den weg
tatsächlich garantierte die regierung
seit dem ersten moment
rechtsstaatlichkeit und niedrige steuern
für alle unternehmen unabhängig davon
woher sie kamen aber nicht nur das
pacelli gab unternehmen und
privatpersonen alle arten von
steueranreizen damit sie investieren und
kapital
mit anderen worten die großen
südkoreanischen konzerne wie hyundai
oder lotte wussten sich auf dem offenen
markt gegen unternehmen aus den usa oder
japan behaupten aber gleichzeitig hatten
sie die hilfe der regierung die
bestimmte wo es für sie lang geht da
südkorea über keine natürlichen
ressourcen verfügt sondern eine große
bevölkerung konzentrieren sich diese
unternehmen auf arbeitsintensive
branchen also vor allem fertigung aber
dies war erst der anfang von das land
der t ball
stellen sie sich das leben eines der
hunderttausend angestellten und südkorea
vor die bei samsung electronics
beschäftigt sind
er war morgens in einem haus auf das von
dem bauunternehmen der samsung gruppe
gebaut wurde wer der frühstück schaut
also ich gerne das neueste risikopolitik
video an wenn das machen clevere leute
nun mal aber auch was schaut er sich an
natürlich auf seinem gelegt die heli von
samsung
dann fährt er mit seinem auto einem
rollos am zur arbeit ja wo fahrzeuge
werden in südkorea von samsung gefertigt
und ratet mal welcher kfz versicherung
sein auto versichert ist richtig geraten
samsung
[Musik]
nach einem harten arbeitstag bei genau
findet auf der südkoreaner mit seinen
kollegen ein paar bierchen trinken geht
also geht einem bar
die gehört sehr gut so wieder richtig
geraten
dann kommt das wochenende und unser
freund wird eine schöne zeit mit seiner
frau und seinen kindern verbringen aber
schließt also sie einen vergnügungspark
mitzunehmen und was glaubst du wo sie
hingehen jena samsung betreibt sein
eigenes disneyland mit anderen worten
wenn du führst du arbeitest ist das
unternehmen alles für dich samstag ist
der größte sogenannte tier wohl des
landes
es war sich sicher was zum teufel ist
ein ball t bonds sind jene großen chor
emirate die vom staat unterstützt werden
einige von ihnen wie die bereits
verschwunden die firma der eu wurden von
der regierung selbst gegründet andere
wie juni in den 40er jahren durch
privatleute
[Musik]
alle von ihnen starteten als
familienunternehmen aber mit der zeit
wurden sie in aktiengesellschaften
umgewandelt an denen jede anteile kaufen
kann und sie alle sind stark
diversifiziert in den
unterschiedlichsten geschäftsfeldern und
branchen zb ist lg bekannt für seine
fernseher und mobiltelefone aber in
südkorea sind sie auch der abfüller und
vertriebspartner von coca cola
insgesamt gibt es etwa 100 sie sind die
eckpfeiler der südkoreanischen
wirtschaft aber wie ich bereits sagte
die regierung rollt für sie den roten
teppich aus was aber nicht bedeutet dass
sie über einen blanko scheck oder
freifahrtschein verfügen aus diesem
grund hat die regierung den ball die
nicht aus der staatskasse gerettet als
dieser auf eine pleite zusteuert
und das ist ein klarer anreiz für diese
unternehmen an der spitze der innovation
zu bleiben so hatte die japanische firma
sony zum beispiel den plan im jahr 2008
mit den ersten oled tvs auf den markt zu
kommen aber die technologie war noch
nicht ausgereift genug und die
bildschirme waren ziemlich teuer selbst
für den luxus macht also legten die
jungs bei sony das projekt erstmal auf
eis die südkoreanische lg hatte zur
gleichen zeit auch amoled-displays
gearbeitet und war auf das gleiche
problem gestellt
[Musik]
was aber taten sie sie führten erst mal
holt handys ein
die eben ein wesentlich kleineres
display brauchen als fernseher auf diese
weise umschifften sie das problem
und was noch wichtiger ist die kunden
nun massiv praktische erfahrungen mit
dieser neuen technologie und ihrer
fertigung sammeln und während die sorry
leute verzagt deutschen treten fand lg
auf diese weise in kurzer zeit einen weg
die fertigungskosten für oleds massiv zu
senken und am ende doch noch
erschwingliche oled fernseher anbieten
zu können
zur dumpfe sony aber wartet eine minute
denn es gibt noch eine weitere wichtige
zutat für die zubereitung einer derart
innovativen kultur koreanische
bildungssystem wir alle wissen ist in
den pisa tests rangieren südkoreanische
kinder immer an der spitze
das ganze land hält den atem an wenn
jedes jahr die zeit der
aufnahmeprüfungen an den unis näher
rückt und den südkoreanischen schulen
ist nichts zu teuer um ihren
schülerinnen und schülern nur die
allerbeste ausbildung zu bieten
die kehrseite der mir daher ist dass
diese kinder die höchste selbstmordrate
unter kindern weltweit haben
eigentlich haben alles südkoreaner
dieses problem dieses land hält unter
den wohlhabenden ländern dieser welt
beständig den spitzenplatz in der
weltrangliste für selbstmorde pro
einwohner und befindet sich damit in der
illustren gesellschaft von ländern wie
lesotho russland und kasachstan
wie aber kam es dazu von anfang an
verstand die regierung dass die tebus
hochqualifizierte arbeitskräfte
benötigen würden so in war sie ein
bildungssystem das genau darauf
ausgerichtet ist maßgeschneiderte
arbeitskräfte für die
unternehmensstrukturen der tirols
auszuspucken
dies erklärt warum südkoreanische kinder
menschliche taschenrechner sind und die
fähigkeit haben sich alles zu merken
respekt vor autorität und hierarchie
trägt fast schon religiöse züge und
deshalb will niemand von ihnen ein
unternehmen gründen
der traum eines jeden südkoreaners ist
es in
der teams zu arbeiten wenn sie nur hart
genug arbeiten würden
möchten sie manager werden und sich ein
haus in jedem paradies auf erden leisten
in jenem berühmten viertel in soul
dessen name mittlerweile ungewollt
weltbekannt geworden ist ja wir sprechen
hier über den stadtteil namens gang nahm
[Musik]
was für ein stil ist eigentlich der
gamestar tagsüber eine menschliches und
warmherziges mädchen sie hat klasse und
weiß die freiheit einer tasse kaffee zu
genießen
aber wenn die nacht zu ende geht wird
der herz wärmer weil sie ein mädchen mit
zwei gesichtern ist haye sexy lady opa
ist games teil dieses im auszug aus
einem liedtext und denen vor ein paar
jahren jeder gesungen hat während er
betrunken war und dieser liedtext
bereitete seinem sänger sei
einige probleme mit den behörden
aufgrund unangemessener inhalte für eine
gesellschaft die von respekt vor
autorität besessen ist ist die ästhetik
des sei etwas so radikal ist wie die
hüfte die grünen von elvis in den 50er
jahren aber das ist nur ein weiteres
symptom eine fakt ist dass ein derartig
hierarchisches wirtschaftssystem das
sich nur auf eine kleine zahl große
unternehmen stößt kein allzu gutes
rezept für eine nachhaltig stabile
volkswirtschaft ist und in der tat ist
in südkorea nur das verarbeitende
gewerbe besonders wettbewerbs
[Musik]
ansonsten die wirtschaft in anderen
bereichen wie dienstleistungen oder
finanzen dem ausland stark hinterher und
da die gesamte wirtschaft unglaublich
stark von den entscheidungen der
regierung und tv bossen abhängig bleibt
für kleine und mittelständische
unternehmen und innovative
unternehmensgründer fast kein platz mehr
denkt mal darüber nach es ist verdammt
hart eine firma zu gründen wenn eure
konkurrenten tatkräftig von der
regierung unterstützt werden und ihr
nicht tatsächlich sind die meisten teams
zur bürokratischen moloch herangewachsen
die unglaublich viel geld verschlingen
um überhaupt funktionieren zu können
dieses sommers führt die rangliste im
verkauf von mobiltelefonen auf der
ganzen welt an allerdings macht sie
damit so gut wie keinen gewinn
und das ist ein problem
allerdings erkennt man langsam in
südkorea dass dieses in der
vergangenheit so erfolgreiche modell an
seine grenzen stößt und langsam beginnen
sich die dinge zu ende
vieles wird koreanische jugendliche
haben in europa oder amerika eine
ausbildung genossen und jetzt kehren sie
mit einer neuen kritischeren kultur und
einer gehörigen portion unternehmergeist
in ihre heimat zurück diese neue
generation kann die grundlagen für ein
gesundes startup ökosystem schaffen
auch sie hier noch sehr viel zu tun
[Musik]
wie auch immer ob es uns gefällt oder
nicht wir müssen zugeben dass das top
down watchers modell in südkorea bisher
großen erfolg hatte trotz allem gibt es
noch einige fragen die zu beantworten
sind
was würde zum beispiel passieren wenn
eines tages ein unternehmen von der
größe ist samsung zusammenbrechen würde
du meinst das wäre unmöglich
dann schau mal was mit dem handy
weltmarktführer nokia in finnland
passiert ist wenn er überhaupt noch
wisst was nokia war
google ist was würde mit einem land wie
südkorea dessen gesellschaft ganz anders
aus dem finnland aufgebaut ist dann
passieren und nicht nur das die
verflechtung zwischen politik und
wirtschaft hat enorme anreize für
korruption im allergrößten umfang
geschaffen
aber das ist ein thema welches wir in
einem anderen video behandeln
[Musik]
in der zwischenzeit solltest du dir
unser video über die zukunftsprobleme
von südkoreas nachbarland japan
anschauen
die frage an euch essen glaubt ihr dass
eine derartige kreuzung von iranischer
obrigkeit und freier marktwirtschaft den
anderen ländern auch funktionieren
könnte welche meinung habt ihr über das
südkoreanische system an sich hat uns
darüber bitte im kommentarbereich
vergesst nicht dass er jede woche neue
videos hochladen werden also verpasst
keines unserer updates und abonniert
unseren kanal und wenn euch dieses video
gefallen hat die uns einen daumen hoch
macht's gut und bis zum nächsten
[Musik]